Well well well. I’m surprised you two came back. I thought I might’ve scared you a little too much last time.
Mm, nothing we can’t handle, right?
Yeah, nothin’ like a few nightmares to get you through the week.
Oh, well good. Because tonight I’ve got a tale that’s gonna leave you both totally trembling.
Ooooooh
So Los Angeles has a lot of bright lights and beautiful people.
But in L.A.’s dark underground, there’s a secret turf war that’s been raging for centuries between humans… and vampires.
Ohh boy.
After so much bloodshed, the two sides signed a truce that lasted a hundred years.
The terms were simple: vampires remain unseen from humans,
don’t drink from the unwilling, and stay out of Boyle Heights.
But some truces just weren’t meant to last.
This story’s called ‘Night Teeth’
Boyle Heights is a neighbourhood in east L.A. run by Jay Perez and his crew.
They protect the truce and keep the vampires out.
But one night, a scheming vampire named Victor breaks the truce.
He busts into Boyle Heights, kills some of Jay’s crew, and kidnaps his girlfriend, Maria.
Maria!
This not only enrages Jay
It pisses off the bosses of L.A.’s vampire underworld.
They’ve grown rich and powerful during the truce, and wanna punish Victor too.
Which is exactly what he planned for.
Victor wants all that heat?
Oh ya.
Now on the non-bloodsucking side of town, there’s Jay’s brother Benny.
Benny’s a sweet college kid, who doesn’t even know vampires exist.
While Jay prepares to save Maria, Benny takes his place driving for their limo company.
Little does Benny know, he’s cruising right into Victor’s plan.
While everyone’s after him, Victor’s got his vampire girlfriend, Zoe, and her vampire BFF Blaire,
going around L.A. to kill the 5 bosses, then their driver, who’s supposed to be Jay.
We’re hitting every single one of these parties tonight and we need to get to the last stop by morning.
That’s non-negotiable. Are we clear?
Ya.
And if Victor takes out all his enemies in one night
He runs Los Angeles.
Exactly. Victor planned to break the truce, kill everyone, and take over.
As for Benny? He’s in the scariest spot ever.
Unknowingly driving around two vicious vampire assassins.
On an early stop, Benny finds a bag of bloody cash in the car. He goes looking for Zoe and Blaire. Ooops -
Hey.
Heh.. Hey
This isn’t what it looks like.
Uh ok then I’ll just –
Oh my god. He’s shaking. I love it when they shake.
Daniel? Daniel!
It’s ok it’s just a story.
Uh, ya for sure, I’m, I’m into it.
Uh, we can see that.
So what happens next?
Oh I can’t give away the ending. Netflix would flip.
Dude, what are you doing?
Night… teeth… spoilers.
Dude! Just go watch it.
Unless of course,
you’re too scared. Hahahaha